country star john rich is now
betting 10 000 that the supreme court
will intervene
and hand the 2020 presidential election
to donald trump
10 grand that's pretty good i mean i
like the
fervor i like the encouragement i like
the support i don't want us to give up
or concede
one single thing until the electors vote
i probably would not put ten thousand
dollars up there one of the reasons i
would not
is because the left
believes they've won it the left is now
totally convinced the strongest evidence
i've seen
of this yet from the daily beast
daily beast writes the seeds of hunter
biden's current legal woes
were found on his laptop
december 9th 2020 the daily beast
is breaking the story about hunter
biden's laptop
which had incriminating information
about his business practices and
personal habits
that story broke in october
but a lot of people didn't hear about
that story breaking in october
because the left-wing media and
big tech most especially covered it up
they actively suppressed the story they
wouldn't let you
share the story they wouldn't let you
send the story in a private message
they knew the story would damage biden
there was a media research center poll
that showed that biden gained something
like 14
points because people didn't know
about the hunter biden story the story
of the biden family corruption
14 of people who voted for biden
according to this one poll said that
they would not have voted for biden had
they known that
and now the left these cynics
and psychopaths will look you right in
the face and say wow can you imagine
this
can you admit look hunter biden has
legal troubles quote
evidence of a money laundering probe
into hunter biden
was apparent in the markings on a series
of documents that were made public
but went largely unnoticed in the days
leading up
to the november election when
why why did it go largely unnoticed
because you active you can't claim
ignorance you can't claim that you
wanted to research it more
you were actively suppressing this
information
now you think that the election is so
beyond
decided that you can come out with this
information
why why leak it now some people think
it's to damage biden because people want
to help
kamala harris a little bit more but
regardless i don't think you even need
to go that far they're doing it because
they think they've already got it
wrapped up and frankly they very well
may
this is what trump has been up against
the whole time he's been up against
obviously
the democratic party obviously the
bureaucracy
the media hollywood big technology
that whole blob has been
actively conspiring against them you
can't say it's just an accident after
reading the daily beast article
that is an active conspiracy